je vous demande d'accueillir c'est une
des plus grandes stars mondiales
je vous jure que c'est vrai et il nous
fait l'honneur d'être avec nous ce soir
pour la fin de l'émission c'est le plus
grand danseur pour moi encore actuelle
c'est sa liste qui est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
s allie savoir que sa vie
effet des chants nazis l'affairé salif
bâ l'on regarde regardez regardez la
regarde et à mon salut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
vous
[Musique]
100 pc ont remercié et je vous dis à la
fois il m'a ramené un truc de ouf c'est
que alors déjà je remercie novak
djokovic et monsieur suis toute ouïe
story sur un stade mais non nova
sinon je voudrais le remercier la vague
de comics qui jouent en demi finale
demain donc ça m'a ça m'a touché et il
ay les pains crois que novak c'est un
homme avec prochain ils dansent hyper
bien en rugby la louve a resserré la
gérer juste novak j'ai parlé beaucoup
d'argent sur toi demain tu le fais pas
pour toi raconte j'ai parié beaucoup
d'argent oui oui oui oui avec mon ami
qui me regardent
voilà je le remercie mes chéris et lala
et deuxième bail je vous jure que c'est
vrai will smith
incroyable scénario mais franchement
j'ai été moi j'ai été surprise sur
toutes les personnes que j'ai
rencontrées juin à perth
enfin aucune m'a pas déçu quoi mais
c'est un abri la dernière fois il ya la
petite baisse de will smith que j'aime
une rue à m'a dit oui 6 m'a demandé de
nouvelles et m'a dit viens quoi le
foulard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
salif
de fait nos meilleurs coaches salif je
vais bien merveilleux
ce soir je veux dire rien j'ai décidé et
c'est très rare ouais j'ai décidé de me
mettre en retrait
je me fous la danse internationale
je sais ça fait partie des mauvais jours
[Musique]
et le meilleur plat c'était ça c'était
quoi
[Applaudissements]
saleh est-ce que du bon d'annoncer une
démo chez vous je n'ai peur moi je me
regardais salif toujours failli je veux
te regarde et 8h salaires cocotte il
commence à se faire vieux je suis
dégoûté les mois c'est la dernière
oui la dernière je veux que du beau que
du beau salif est ce que tu peux nous
faire une petit un petit kiff non je
vous dis rien de faire de l'audience sur
la dernière merci non je rigole m'a dit
bon ça ni franchement a fait une loi qui
fait inquiète passera en retrait je
dansais beaucoup 360
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'essaie
nesta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ce n'est pas toujours comme ça
j'aime bien les pieds moi celui
exceptionnel vraiment c'est quoi là il
ya des choix qui n'ont rien à envier il
ya des très belles choses mais moi là
qu'est ce qui est très beau projet bon
déjà il ya un documentaire avec amazon
prime est là qui arrive surtout ce que
tout ce qui s'est passé depuis ce début
jusqu'à jusqu'au tremplin qui arrive sur
amazon prime et makala gd n'a pas de
dents sur mick hannah le club est en
quête de nature à commander sur amazon
ah oui on est à la dai a encore un
bloc-notes est à ce moment qu ils
adoptent à mentir je le conduisais quoi
fait c'est une émission faune fougueux
baiser bah ouais tu me fais alessio tu
feras tu veux pas faire un truc sur mick
hannah luttons caf amazon la sortir de
là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
direction la gamme avec le cinéma le
cinéma aussi je dus au canal
non non c'est mgm et fox est un qui sait
ya eu au sein du groupe sein du groupe
tom tu n'as aucun projet malheureusement
laissé ma carte sans merci me faut la
refaire un s'il vous plaît avant
d'arriver à la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu
l'auteur des coups de cornes attente
auprès des brasseurs avec les airs
[Applaudissements]